herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF heute live
schön dass ihr wieder dabei seid wir
gucken hier heute wie jede Woche auf den
russischen Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine
wir besprechen dazu die aktuelle Lage an
der Front wir besprechen das Thema
militärische Unterstützung wir sprechen
aber auch über die russischen Angriffe
die die Ukraine abseits der Front
treffen lst uns mal reingucken jeden Tag
gibt es neue erschütternde Bilder in der
vergangene Nacht ein Luftangriff auf die
zweitgrößte ukrainische Stadt harkiv
dabei starb ein zehnjähriger Junge mehr
als 20 Menschen wurden verletzt nicht
weal von harkiv war erst gestern eine
Rakete in einen Dorfladen und ein cffee
eingeschlagen dort wurden mindestens 50
Menschen getötet wenige Bilder dagegen
von der Front hier im Süden wo
ukrainische Soldaten auch nach
durchbrechen russischer
Verteidigungslinien weiter nur mühsam
und oft nur zu Fuß voran
ankmen ja scheinbar wenig Bewegung an
der Front aber was bedeutet das für den
Verlauf des Krieges und wie steht es
eigentlich um die Gegenoffensive welchen
Chancen hat sie noch und wie viel Zeit
bleibt ihr noch darüber wollen wir heute
hier bei ZF live diskutieren und zwar
mit folgenden Gästen mit dem
militärökonomen Markus Kolb und der ZDF
reporterin Anne Brühl die uns live aus
der Ukraine zugeschaltet ist und wie
immer auch mit euch wenn ihr gerade
zuschaut und sagt hey dazu habe ich eine
Frage das habe ich noch nicht verstanden
oder hierzu möchte ich einfach mal meine
Meinung sagen dann tut das wie immer
gerne einfach hier im Youtube Chat oder
per Mail an die unten eingeblendete
Adresse jetzt legen wir aber erstmal los
und schauen direkt mal auf den
Frontverlauf und auf die Front die
momentan überall in Bewegung ist
zumindest sagt er das Markus Kolb
schönen guten
Abend hallo guten Abend grüß Herr K wir
gucken jetzt mal im Detail darauf was wo
an der Front passiert und wir fangen mal
an mit
der Gegend rund um robotine also dort in
der Oblast saporija das ist im Süden der
Ukraine dort ist seit der Rückeroberung
des Dorfes robotine nicht mehr so
richtig viel Bewegung zu sehen oder
zumindest ist ja nicht viel
Geländegewinn zu
beobachten ja das ist genau das
Stichwort das ist ein Aspekt den viele
Journalisten falsch bewerten meiner
Ansicht nach nämlich dieser einseitige
Fokus auf den
Bewegungskrieg man muss sich zunächst
mal klar machen er Krieg findet in
Phasen statt nämlich Abnutzung Bewegung
Abnutzung Bewegung und wir sind im
Moment in einer abnutzungsphase das
bedeutet gerade weil die Ukraine sich
eben durch die russischen Minenfelder
durcharbeiten muss kommt sie natürlich
in Quadratmeter oder Quadratkilometer
Gelände gemessen relativ langsam voran
und das ä das veranlastst n manche
Journalisten die New York Times z. macht
das immer gerne
quasi zu sagen okay wie viel
Quadratmeter oder Quadratkilometer habt
ihr eigentlich schon zurück rückerobert
was so wenig um Gottes Willen die
Offensive ist gescheitert ja so ganz
einfach ist es aber nicht äh ich habe
sie haben mir vorhin gesagt die Front
bewegt sich ja und wenn wir mal
anschauen was bewegt sich ähm im
Hinterland der Front explodiert die
russische Artillerie die bewegt sich und
zwar in die Luft mit lautem Knall und
großem Feuerball und genau das ist
eigentlich der Punkt wir sind also im
Moment in einer Lage wo die Ukraine
etwas sehr bemerkenswertes macht sie
schießt die russische Artillerie vor
allem in diesem Sektor den wir jetzt
hier sehen geradezu reihenweise ab auch
tokmar also dieser das eigentliche Ziel
der Offensive ist bereits in
feuerdistanz und wir sehen bereits
russische Artillerie die südlich von
tokmar steht und schon herausgenommen
wird also gerade jetzt zu Beginn Oktober
und dessen muss man sich klar sein es
geht also hier nicht darum in in
irgendwelcher selbstmörderischer Art
durch durch Gräben und Minenfelder
durchzubrechen das wäre militärisch
unsinnig sondern die Ukraine setzt hier
im Moment auf die Abnutzung und dabei
nutzt ihr vor allem die
die US clustermunition also die
sogenannte depckem dual purpose improved
conventionalition weil die sehr sehr
erfolgreich sich erwiesen hat bei der
Neutralisierung dieser Artillerie und da
gibt's auch keinen Munitionsmangel ne
allein die USA haben 3 Millionen Stück
davon in ihren Lager und wenn sie sich
die Statistiken angucken auch die farms
Satelliten der NASA also die diese die
die Feuer in der Natur erfassen und
damit benutzt werden können um
Artillerie auszuwerten das bemerkenswert
wie stark hier die Zerstörung der
russischen Artillerie voranschreitet und
das muss man eben beides sehen und
vergleichen kann man das mit dem was vor
etwa einem Jahr passiert ist nämlich die
Rückeroberung von resson da hat auch
jeder gesagt ja passiert ja nichts
bewegt sich nichts und dann waren
plötzlich alle überrascht dass Ron im
November ganz plötzlich befreit wurde ne
also diesen Rhythmus den den muss man
begreifen und und verstehen wie Bewegung
und Abnutzung Zusammenhängen sie sagen
gerade die Ukrainer bemühen sich aktuell
darum dass die Artillerie der Russen in
die Luft Geschoss ossen wird also eine
Phase der Abnutzung in diesem Krieg und
das würde eigentlich gar nicht so
schlecht aussehen wie passt es denn da
zusammen dass die Russen ja zuletzt auch
noch Truppen in diese Region verlegt
haben weil also ist es denn eine
berechtigte Befürchtung dass sich quasi
weiter südlich von robotine noch weitere
russische Soldaten eingraben also lauert
die Gefahr quasi noch weiter hinten na
eingraben würde ich nicht sagen aber die
Gefahr die in robotine bestand im Laufe
des September war einfach dass dort ein
doch entsteht weil die nämlich von
relativ schwach ausgestatteten Verbänden
gehalten wird also von von modorized
rifles von mobix und von Bars
Regimentern und deswegen hat man die
7bte und 76 luftlandedivision abgezogen
aus dem östlichen Kampfraum also vor
allem dem Raum bachmut und dorthin
verlegt also quasi um um der die dortige
Front zu stärken das Problem ist dass
diese Einheiten selber mittlerweile zu
über 50% abgenutzt sind das hat ein
russischer militärblocker übrigens im
russischen fern sind selbst zugegeben
das heißt ähm diese Verbände äh die die
können sozusagen das ein bisschen
aufhalten aber irgendwann sind die auch
abgekämpft und ähm so zumindest nachdem
was was ich mir angeschaut habe hat
Russland eigentlich kaum mehr Reserven
die in diesen Raum verlegt werden können
das heißt die die Frage ist nicht so
sehr eingraben sondern die Frage ist wie
lange können Sie die Front noch halten
und es lohnt sich jetzt wirklich so die
nächsten zwei Wochen in diesen Raum zu
schauen weil ähm was wir beobachten
müssten wenn dieser wenn dieser Sektor
auf geht ist eine Absetzbewegung der
Russen man muss den Russen eines lassen
was sie wirklich können ist Rückzug ähm
haben wir letztes Jahr auch gesehen bei
chon da hat haben so manche gesagt ja es
gibt ein Massaker und S werden alle im
nipo ertrinken und als dann Fron
zurückerobert wurde waren sie plötzlich
alle weg ähm also sprich es lohnt sich
nach tokmark zu schauen gibt es dort
Absetzbewegungen ähm fliehen die
Kollaborateure flieht ähm die
Zivilverwaltung die von den Russen
eingesetzt wurde flieh der FSB weil sie
müssen sich vorstellen ähm das
zusammenpacken an der Front ist passiert
von hinten also sie stellen quasi vorne
an die Front Leute die bis zum Schluss
durchhalten und wahrscheinlich sind das
arme mobiks die die überwiegend drauf
gehen werden und im Hinterland packt die
Front zusammen und zieht sich zurück in
den nächsten Raum also eingraben halte
ich eher für unwahrscheinlich ich glaube
dass ich eher hier die Schwäche der
russischen Grabensysteme zeigt nämlich
eine sehr sehr stark ausgebaute erste
Linie aber dahinter kommt eine viel
schwächere zweite und dahinter kommt n
mehr also man muss auch ganz klar sagen
es stehen im Hinterland kaum Reserven
Russland kämpft eigentlich vor seinen
Gräben nicht nur hier in dbertine
sondern auch im Raum bachmut und
unterliegt entsprechend einer einer sehr
hohen Abnutzung ja Abnutzung also lassen
Sie uns mal auf die zweite Karte gucken
auf den nächsten Frontabschnitt rund um
uroine das ist ein Ort der wurde auch
vor einigen Wochen zurück erobert und
seitdem wenn man da jetzt mal ganz von
oben drauf guckt ganz oberflächlich gibt
es dort relativ wenig Bewegung oder
ähm konventionelle mechanische Bewegung
ja
von ukrainischer Seite das stimmt schon
aber die Abnutzung auf der russischen
Seite die können sie sehr sehr deutlich
sehen ich bin geneigt diese ganze Woche
die wir jetzt hinter uns haben als die
Woche des russischen blechhaufens zu
betrachten
weil es gab hier einen Angriff den die
Russen versucht haben also ausgehend von
stadomelinivka in Richtung udoine also z
sie haben versucht die die Ukrainer
zurückzudräen das ist ihn allerdings
misslungen und das es gab dann
spektakuläre Abschüsse von russischen
gepanzerten Fahrzeugen glaube es waren
so acht oder ja acht Fahrzeuge insgesamt
die dabei drauf gegangen sind das
Interessante ist nicht so sehr ähm
eigentlich die Abnutzung sondern wie
diese Fahrzeuge gefahren sind es gibt ja
so manche die sagen die Russen lernen
aus ihren Fehlern oder die Russen werden
taktisch langsam besser als ich mir das
angeguckt auf der Karte habe ich gesagt
nee sie machen die gleichen Fehler immer
wieder und solange das so passiert also
solange sie sie sehen das jetzt hier an
der Karte ne urine liegt direkt an der
Kampflinie die Russen stehen vor ihren
Gräben also vor diesen roten
durchgezeichneten Linien und werden auch
vor diesen Gräben abgenutzt und solange
sie das so machen ist das militärisch so
ziemlich das Dümmste was sie machen
können eigentlich müssten sie sich
zurückziehen in die Grabensysteme selber
also in die elastische Verteidigung
gehen dann hätte es die Ukraine viel
viel schwerer da durchzukommen aber
solange diese Gräben nicht wirklich
besetzt und mit Reserven verstärkt sind
und solange sieor den Gräben stehen im
offenen Gelände solange macht das nicht
wirklich Sinn sie sagen jetzt die Russen
lernen eigentlich schon seit einer
ganzen Weile militärstrategisch nicht
wirklich dazu das was sie gerade
beschreiben das war ja schon Anfang des
Jahres wo man ähnliches Verhalten
beobachtet hat woran liegt das in ihrer
Einschätzung nach ach das liegt an
vielen Dingen einerseits natürlich an
der üblichen sowjetischen Doktrin das
heißt
also es es gibt ja in der russischen
Armee kein kein Kader von
Unteroffizieren die quasi die Front
genau kennen und die die taktisch äm
flexibel umgehen können mit der Truppe
sondern es gibt nur die Offiziere ähm
und und dann die die die sehr große
Kaste der Mannschaften äh und und das
ist ein absolut hierarchisches topdown
Verhältnis wenn jetzt die Offiziere
ein Haltebefehl bekommen also von Putin
selber oder von schuge oder wie auch
immer und und der heißt nicht
zurückweichen dann machen sie das
genauso und wenn das heißt dass da
tausende von Leuten drauf gehen tausende
von System ist egal aber Widerspruch ist
unmöglich in diesem System das ist das
eine das andere ist ähm die T t dass
Putin zwar Loyalität belohnt aber nicht
Kompetenz es gab gerade in dem Abschnitt
den wir jetzt angeschaut haben sehr
fähigen Kommandeur den generaluten und
popof Kommand 58 die derzeit im Raum
robertine steht der ist abgesetzt worden
und durch romanschu ersetzt worden und
popof war so dumm wirklich sehr
intelligent und sehr luzide
herauszuarbeiten wo die Schwächen der
der russischen Strategie liegen zwei
Tage später war er weg ersetzt durch
romanchuk und was macht romanchuk halten
um jeden Preis solange sie solche
Generäle haben äh kann die Ukraine froh
sein weil die Arbeiten letztlich äh zu
Gunsten der Ukraine und ähm es es ist
schwer es ist schwer das wirklich
rational ähm zu verstehen es hat sehr
viel mit dieser mit dieser sowjetischen
Kultur zu tun die immer noch sehr stark
in der russischen Armee äh vorhanden ist
ja also historisch bedingt sie haben uns
auch noch Information mitgebracht zu
Mari jinker das liegt in der Nähe äh zu
der schon seit 2014 besetzen stad donj
im Osten der Ukraine lassen sie uns da
mal auf die Karte schauen hier suumen
wir einmal rein was ist dort zuletzt
passiert an diesem Frontabschnitt ja
eigentlich das das gleiche also
Stichwort Woche des russischen
blechhaufens es gab
nördlich und südlich von mariinka zwei
große Angriffe der Russen vermutlich am
5 und am 25 September nageln sie mich
jetzt mal nicht auf den Tag genau fest
die quasi versucht haben diesen Raum
nördlich und und südlich
zu umfassen oder oder dort hin
vorzustoßen das war ebenfalls ein
komplettes disaster also diese Kolonnen
von gepanzerten Fahrzeugen die
davorgestoßen sind sind ebenfalls
abgeschossen worden und ä es gilt hier
das gleiche was ich vorhin gesagt habe
solange sie in dieser Art und Weise
versuchen anzugreifen oder sich
durchzusetzen gegen die ukrainische
Taktik ähm solange ist das nicht
wirklich zielführend wir merken jetzt
vielleicht was ich gemeint habe mit die
Front bewegt sich ja also wir haben
nicht diesen diesen Prozess der des
klassischen geländegewinns sondern wir
haben den Prozess ähm russische
gepanzerte Dinge bewegen sich und
fliegen dann in die Luft und ich ich
kann nur sagen bitte machen Sie weiter
so weil je mehr von denen in die Luft
fliegen desto früher ist der Krieg
vorbei
ähm wir haben jetzt ja eigentlich bei
zwei Karten sie sagen das auch die ganze
Zeit ähnliche Strategien beobachtet wir
haben aber auch von russischen
Gegenangriffen gehört die haben sie auch
eben erwähnt wie müssen wir denn das
deuten ist es so eine Art
Vorwärtsverteidigung ist es dazu da um
die gegen Offensive zum Stoppen zu
bringen ist es wirklich ein russischer
Angriff
nein also es sind tatsächlich Angriffe
äh also sie sie müssen sich das so
vorstellen wenn die Russen sowas machen
dann gehen sie richtig stark mit
Material herein das ist also nicht so so
ein vorsichtiges antesten sondern sie
versammeln dann wirklich eine eine
Kolonne von gepanzerten Fahrzeugen und
versuchen da durchzubrechen auch unter
in kaufnahme hoher Verlust und und mit
großer Brutalität man darf das also
schon nicht unterschätzen
aber Sie sehen dass Sie da it einfach
nicht mehr durchkommen ne das ist im
Prinzip immer noch die Strategie die wir
aus dem Sommer 22 kennen
alles kaputt schießen und dann vorrücken
aber beides wird schwierig weil alles
kaputt schießen wird immer schwieriger
weil sie immer weniger Artillerie haben
man muss sich ja mal denken die größte
artilleristische Armee des eurasischen
Kontinents ist mittlerweile s weit
abgenutzt dass sie eine fast gleiche
feuerfrequenz hat wie die Ukraine die zu
Beginn des Krieges viel schwächer war
bei der Artillerie also sprich dieser
dieser historische Vorteil den sie noch
aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg herüber
genommen haben der erodiert zunehmend
und das zweite ist natürlich wenn sie so
umgehen mit ihren gepanzerten Fahrzeugen
klar da können sie sagen okay ich habe
noch endlos im Depot aber ich habe mir
gerade diese Woche wieder
Satellitenfotos angeschaut von den
verschiedenen russischen Depots also den
Lagern über ganz Russland wo die drinne
stehen und das sehen Sie ein massives
sich Lehren dieser Lager ja ich sage das
vor allem an die Adresse derer die immer
sagen FK of war und wir können nichts
wissen und schalala oh doch wir können
wissen wenn wir uns ein bisschen
anstrengen und
wenn sie sich wirklich mal bemühen das
das zu sehen dann dann sehen Sie was
Abnutzung in der Praxis heißt sehen wir
übrigens auch bei der Artillerie also
auch selbstfahrende Geschütze werden
ausgeschlachtet also das Fahrwerk lässt
man stehen das Kanonenrohr transportiert
man ab an die Front offenbar weil man
die Logistik nicht mehr hat für für die
Ersatzteile
also das alles zeichnet ein Bild dass
sie von einer Armee die bisher sich
verlassen hat darauf wir haben sehr
große Reserven aber dieses Argument das
gilt zunehmend nicht mehr und wenn das
Argument nicht mehr gilt was machen sie
dann oder und das ist ein Moment der
Wahrheit der spätestens diesen Winter
denke ich für die russische Armee kommen
wird und jetzt schauen wir abschließend
noch mal auf die Region bachmut dort
wurden zuletzt von der ukrainischen
Armee einige Ortschaften wieder
eingenommen wir Zoomen hier einmal rein
und sehen dort in schwarz eingezeichnet
auch die Eisenbahnlinien in der Region
wie schätzen sie denn die Gegenoffensive
dort in der Region aktuell
ein ja ich würde sagen da haben wir
tatsächlich Bewegung gehabt also das das
waren nicht nur einige Ortschaften das
war ein ganzer Sektor den die Ukraine
zurück erobert hat z.B auch den den Ort
klisivka der jetzt nicht auf der Karte
ist aber wichtiger ist das was hier auf
der Karte ist nämlich kurdiumivka und
zwar aus einem einfachen Grund kum mifka
liegt etwas erhöht also so auf einer auf
einer Bodenwelle kann man sich
vorstellen also etwa 30 m über dem
übrigen Gelände und eignet sich deswegen
hervorragend als Standort für die
Artillerie wenn sie da stehen dann
können Sie im Prinzip die ganze
russische Versorgung südlich von bachmut
kontrollieren also sprich unterbinden
ähm und insbesondere die
Straßenverbindung die liegt etwas rechts
dieser schwarzen Eisenbahnlinie also
etwas östlich die sehen wir jetzt gerade
nicht aber über diese Straße
ähm wird ein Teil der russischen
Versorgung äh nach bachmut herangeeführt
also die Idee ist ähm sie schließen die
Operation ab mit der Rückeroberung von
kurumivka Stellen Artillerie auf diese
Höhe und unterbinden damit nicht nur den
gesamten Transportsektor sondern sie
schießen von dort auch das dritte
russische armeekor zusammen oder besser
gesagt die Reste dieses armeekors die
dort noch stehen es ist in diesem Raum
etwas interessantes passiert sehen wir
ganz selten im Krieg nämlich die
vollständige Vernichtung eines ganzen
Truppenteils nämlich der 72 die stand
dort in diesem Raum von pris schevka
wurde vollständig eingeschlossen und
vernichtet inklusive sämtlicher
Offiziere die die 72 kommandiert haben
ähm das ist schon sehr sehr
bemerkenswert normalerweise dürften sie
das nicht zulassen dass eine Einheit
vollständig eingeschlossen und und
vernichtet wird aber das das ist war
zeigt ih was ich vorhin gesagt habe
dieses sorglose umgehen mit Mensch und
Material das wird sich reächen und ich
denke das ist ein Sektor wo man wieder
verstärkt hinschauen muss in diesem
Sektor sind viele russische Truppen
gebunden und
m das verhindert nun eben
dass aus diesem Sektor noch mehr
Reserven an dieser pororisia Front
verlegt werden also spricht man muss das
in Verbindung sehen diese frontsektoren
die wir jetzt
miteinander vergleichen einer meiner
Follower hat das ja mal so schön
russenping P genannt das heißt also wenn
sie äh wenn sie ins Problem haben dass
an der gesamten Frontlinie der Druck
gleichmäßig aufrecht erhalten wird und
ihr Material sich immer weiter abnutzt
dann haben sie irgendwann das Problem
wenn sie jetzt Einheiten Verlegen von A
nach B um die Lücke in B zu stopfen dann
fehlt ihnen die in a und dann entsteht
in a eine neue Lücke dann verlegen Sie
die wieder zurück dann entsteht in B
eine zweite Lücke und so weiter und so
weiter und das heißt je länger dieses
Spiel andauert äh desto mehr sind sie
auf ihre Reserven angewiesen wenn sie
jetzt aber keine Reserven mehr haben
dann können Sie langfristig diese Front
nicht mehr halten genau das ist das
Problem deswegen habe ich auch immer
wieder gesagt
die diese Lage ist eigentlich
strategisch verloren sie können die noch
aufrechterhalten eine gewisse Zeit bis
ihre bis ihre letzten Lager leer sind
und dann wird die Front schlichtweg
kollabieren lassen Sie uns noch mal sie
haben das gerade schon kurz angerissen
auf das Thema Logistik schauen in kurum
mifka ist ja eben diese Eisenbahnlinie
die wirklich direkt da schauplatz ist
wir müssen wir uns daschen vorstellen
wurde die zuletzt noch ganz aktiv auch
von den Russen genutzt obwohl die da
mitten im Gefecht lag ja äh nein die
Eisenbahnlinie können Sie natürlich
nicht mehr Nutzen für die Logistik aber
die Eisenbahnlinie also es ist genau
gesagt ein Damm der ist etwas erhöht
über dem übrigen Gelände ähm das ist
natürlich eine eine natürliche Linie die
die kämpfenden Fraktionen voneinander
trennt und was die Ukraine jetzt die
letzten Tage geschafft hat ist äh im
südlichen Abschnitt also sprich etwas
etwas vor kordiomifka diese Bahnlinie zu
überwinden also die eigentliche
Kampflinie verläuft jetzt etwas östlich
der Bahnlinie und das ist der
eigentliche Punkt also also nicht dass
da jetzt noch irgendwelche Züge darauf
fahren sondern dass sie diese Bahnlinie
als Hindernis überwinden und dann in die
Lage versetzt werden ihre Artillerie
dorthin zu transportieren weil ab dann
definiert die Artillerie einen Raum von
ungefähr 20 bis 30 km man kann sich das
ein vorstellen wie ein Quadrat das
können sie einzeichnen direkt östlich
von von K MKA und alles was in diesem
Quadrat steht kann die Artillerie im
Prinzip Zusammenschießen und das da
stehen jetzt eben die Reste des dritten
armeekurs der Russen und wenn das
passiert dann bekommt die ganze
wachmutfront ein Problem so viel also
mal zum aktuellen Stand an der Front
Herr Kolb wir sprechen uns gleich noch
mal wir sprechen über weitere westliche
Unterstützung und vor allem klären wir
eure Fragen davon gibt's schon jede
Menge hier im Chat jetzt schalten wir
aber erstmal zu meiner ZDF Kollegin Anne
Brühl in die Ukraine die war viel in
harkiv das ist der Ort von dem ich am
Anfang gesprochen habe der jetzt wieder
angegriffen wurde jetzt ist sie uns aber
live aus dem Westen der Ukraine
zugeschaltet aus Ternopil hallo
Anne
hallo ja diese russischen Angriffe wir
haben die Bilder ganz am Anfang der
Sendung gesehen warum ist denn gerade
die Region um halkiv aktuell so heftig
unter Beschuss wie bewertest du diese
Angriffe na der Angriff von gestern der
hat schon für großes Entsetzen gesorgt
es hat einen sehr kleinen Ort getroffen
mehr als 50 Tote und
weit weg von der Front dann doch
entfernt bis zu 40 km und
auch das Ziel das hat hier vielen Sorgen
gemacht nämlich offenbar wurde ja eine
Trauergesellschaft angegriffen nach
einem soldatenbegräbnis und diese
soldatenbegräbnisse die finden hier
überall an jedem Tag in sehr vielen
Orten der Ukraine statt natürlich ist
diese Region kopiansk interessant weil
die Russen dort seit Wochen versuchen
vorzustoßen eine weitere Front
aufzumachen ähm sie stehen dort mit
einer riesigen Armee
110.000 Soldaten so sagen dass die
Ukrainer ja gleich zu Beginn des Kriegs
schon mal von den Russen besetzt für gut
7 Monate wurde dann letztes Jahr in
dieser herbstoffensive wieder befreit
aber natürlich ist kupiansk wichtig wie
wichtig das zeigt vielleicht auch ähm
Präsident selenski der war am Dienstag
noch dort
genau in die dieser Gegend um kopjansk
um seine Soldaten zu
besuchen ja also ein eine Region von
strategisch wichtiger Bedeutung du hast
ja in den letzten Tagen auch immer
wieder mit der Zivilbevölkerung
gesprochen wie gehen die Menschen denn
dort mit diesen dauernden Angriffen um
und wie gucken Sie auf die nächste
Zeit das ist manchmal wirklich schwer zu
beschreiben dass ich würde das sagen das
ist so eine Mischung aus stoisch weil
diese täglichen Angriffe das ist einfach
Alltag für die Menschen hier im Land und
auf der anderen Seite jeder den ich hier
kenne der guckt morgens als erstes auf
sein Handy auf die Nachrichten die
meistens schlechte sind weil es nämlich
wieder verletzte Tote in vielen Städten
der Ukraine gegeben hat und heute morgen
wurde das Land wach mit der Nachricht
auch frakif russische Raketen auf die
Innenstadt übrigens ein Ort da habe ich
ganz in der Nähe letzte Woche noch für
euch geschaltet ich WE ja mit meinem
Team bis Sonntag in hakiv und unsere
letzte Nacht dort die war auch sehr laut
es gab russische Angriffe mit 3 S 100
Raketen das ist dann so man hört erst
eine Explosion dann kommt der Alarm dann
rennt man ins Badezimmer weil das
vermeintlich sicherer ist weil ein dort
dann zwei Wände schützen aber hakif
liegt eben sehr sehr nah an der
russischen Grenze die Raketen die kommen
aus belgorot und vom Start einer solchen
Rakete bis zum Einschlag in hakev das
dauert gerade mal 40
Sekunden ja ziemlich eindrücklich was du
uns da erzählst also danke für diese
Eindrücke jetzt ist es ja so dass wir
gerade diese Taurus Lieferung immer
wieder debattiert haben der aktuelle
Stand ist dass Kanzler Olaf Scholz
derzeit keine taurusraketen an die
Ukraine liefern will die sind ja
eigentlich von der Ukraine gefordert
stattdessen sagt er jetzt für den Winter
aber ein weiteres Flugabwehrsystem vom
Typ Patriot zu das ist was anderes als
von der Ukraine gefordert wie reagiert
man denn deiner Meinung nach im Land
gerade auf diese
Neuigkeiten na ja also zuerstmal ist das
natürlich eine gute Nachricht so ein
Patriot System und um die geht's hier
auch weil man sie natürlich zur
Luftverteidigung braucht und Präsident
selenski sie ja immer wieder gefordert
hat Annalena berberg zul letzte beim
Treffen der Außenminister hier in kiefev
auch noch mal von diesem
winterschutzschild gesprochen hat denn
der Winter steht bevor die russischen
Angriffe auf die Infrastruktur die
werden größer und zur Verteidigung
braucht man natürlich auch solche
Systeme das ist aber natürlich nur einen
Tropfen auf dem heißen Stein ein Patriot
System damit kann man nur einen
überschaubaren Raum verteidigen und
diese Angriffe die finden ich habe es ja
schon so oft gesagt hier im ganzen Land
statt und was Taurus anbelangt natürlich
verfolgt man diese Diskussion man hört
die Äußerungen des Bundeskanzlers in
Granada der sein Zögern ja mit der Sorge
vor einer weiteren Eskalation begründet
und viele hier fragen sich
was mehr an Eskalation kann hier denn
noch passieren und die Ukraine weiß sie
ist auf diese Unterstützung des Westens
einfach
angewiesen Anne ich danke dir für deine
Eindrücke von verort und wünsche dir
alles Gute in die
Ukraine
danke
so und über die weitere militärische
Unterstützung der Ukraine auf die
schauen wir jetzt noch mal mit
militärökonom Markus Kolb der uns gerade
schon mal kurz wieder zugeschaltet war
hallo Herr Kolb hallo grüß ja auch an
sie noch mal die Frage vorerst keine
taurusraketen an die Ukraine ein
weiteres Patriot System heute gab es
auch Medienberichte die darüber sprechen
dass es eventuell mehrere Patriot
Systeme von Deutschland für die Ukraine
geben darf wie bewerten sie
das ja ich habe die Meldung heute auch
gelesen und ich habe mir gedacht ach
Gott ein Patriot System doch so viele
für den zweitgrößten Flächenstaat
Europas was auch nur gilt wenn man bei
Frankreich Französisch Giana mitzählt
also wie ihre Korrespondentin hat es
völlig richtig gesagt Patriot ist zwar
ein sehr fähiges System aber es wird
eben eingesetzt für lokale Verteidigung
das heißt also sie haben ein relativ
engen Radius um ein solches System dass
sie äh wo den sie damit schützen können
die Ukraine hat aber eine Fläche von
600.000 qukm ungefähr wie schützen Sie
so ein Land und da gibt's eine ganz
einfache Regel die beste
Luftverteidigung besteht darin die Basen
und Raketen des Gegners
abzuschießen Punkt
ähm wenn sie sich passiv hinstellen und
betören lassen von der russischen
Propaganda und ihren blöff von der
nukleardrohung und was noch alles und
dann sagen ach Gottchen äh nein das
wollen wir lieber nicht aber dafür
kriegt ein Patriot dann ist das schon
recht zynisch in meinen Augen
vor allem weil man damit eben zivile
Opfer und und Kriegsverbrechen dieser
Art wie wir sie gerade gesehen haben ja
letzt sich letzt sich nichts
entgegensetzen kann ähm man muss sich
klar machen von wo kommt die Rakete von
militärischen Zielen von Schiffen von
abschussbasen von flugbasen
wo von wo kommt die Rakete sie kommt
insbesondere von der Krim also
insbesondere auch von ukrainischenem
Staatsgebiet das derzeit russisch
besetzt ist also dieses vorgeschobene
Argument ja aber damit könnte man Ziele
in Russland treffen das ist im Prinzip
richtig aber solange der Raketenbeschuss
von der Krim kommt ist es nicht
glaubwürdig
also ich sehe keinen technischen Grund
der ja häufig auch gerne vorgeschoben
wird warum das nicht ginge ich sehe auch
keinen militärischen Grund es hat
offenbar emotionale Gründe oder man will
halt einfach warten wie immer Stichwort
Führungsanspruch ne Führung
besteht darin dass man auf die
Amerikaner wartet äh
wir haben ja recht ermutigende Signale
von der beiden Administration also
vielleicht kommt attackems dann schon im
November
und wenn das kommt dann besteht also
definitiv kein Grund mehr an diesen
vorgeschobenen Argumenten festzuhen sie
sagen gerade ein Patriot System bringt
nicht so wirklich viel weil das vor
allem Lokal abwert jetzt gab es heute
aber auch Medienberichte die gespr die
davon gesprochen haben dass es eventuell
drei Patriot Systeme geben könnte die
von Deutschland in die Ukraine gehen
würden würde das dann ein Unterschied
machen ja gut dann haben sie halt drei
Tropfen auf dem heißen Stein statt einen
ne aber Sie können ja wenn Sie wenn Sie
jetzt gerade vorm Bildschirm sitzen sie
können ja mal selber gucken wo diese
Patriot Systeme im Moment stehen sie
können mal in der Wikipedia
recherchieren was haben die eigentlich
für ein Radius und dann zeichnen Sie die
mal ein auf der Karte und dann sehen Sie
die von Patriot geschützten Systeme in
der Ukraine versus die nicht geschützten
Landstriche natürlich ist Patriot nicht
die einzige luftverteil ist klar es gibt
auch andere aber Sie können einen so
großen Flächenstaat nicht gegen gegen
kontinuierlichen Raketen und
bombenbeschuss schützen indem sie alles
vollpflastern mit mit stationärer
bodenbundener airdefense also so viel
Systeme gibt's in der ganzen Welt nicht
das muss man mal ganz klar sagen und
ihre Korrespondentin hat es ebenfalls
ser richtig gesagt was soll denn bitte
noch eskalieren also sprich wie viel
tote Zivilisten brauchen sie eigentlich
noch ich weiß es nicht ich ich bin kein
Politiker und ich entscheide das auch
nicht ich kann Ihnen einfach nur sagen
was was ich technisch und und logistisch
von dem Argument
halte sie haben vorhin immer wieder
davon gesprochen dass wir uns gerade in
der abnutzungsphase in diesem Krieg
befinden jetzt wird auch immer wieder
darüber gesprochen dass auch den
Ukrainern die Munition ausginge so wir
sind also in ein Situation sie sagen da
passiert nicht viel Bewegung es
passieren trotzdem wichtige Dinge einige
User gucken jetzt aber schon auf den
Winter hier fragt z.B chris ist zu
erwarten dass die ukrainischen Truppen
ab Winter inbruch nicht mehr vorrücken
können und die Russen neue Minen
verlegen oder sind die Ukrainer in der
Lage auch im Winter
weiterzumachen also zum zum Thema des
munitionsmangels möchte ich zunächst mal
sagen den Munitionsmangel hat man im
Sommer diesen Jahres diskutiert und zwar
vor allem bei der Artillerie das war
aber bevor die Ukraine diese
klustermunition bekommen hat von der ich
zu Anfang der Sendung gesprochen habe
also die PEN du purp improved Convention
und ich sag's noch mal an dieser Stelle
von dieser Munition haben allein die USA
3 Millionen Stück also wenn ich Stück
sage meine ich
Artilleriegranaten und sie sehen das
auch auf den firm Satelliten also wenn
Sie das das Feuer im Gelände beobachten
dann haben sie eine deutlich stärkere
schagkraft der ukrainischen Artillerie
und das liegt insbesondere an dieser
Munition ähm das heißt ähm die ist nicht
nur sehr wirkungsvoll als
artilleriewaffe sondern es gibt auch
kein Munitionsmangel was die angeht und
ich denke das war eine der besten
Entscheidungen überhaupt diese Munition
der Ukraine zur Verfügung zu stellen
also insofern ja sie kann nicht nur den
Winter durchkämpfen sie kann sehr sehr
lange mit dieser Artillerie die
russischen Systeme neutralisieren äh bis
bis da die Lager leer sind aber
natürlich ähm ist es weiterhin wichtig
die europäische Rüstungsindustrie
anzuwerfen um alles andere ebenfalls
nachzu produzieren also ich habe das ja
früher schon gesagt wir sind in der
gleichen Lage wieder so ein bisschen wie
im ersten oder wie im Zweiten Weltkrieg
der Krieg bricht aus er ist viel größer
als gedacht er kommt unerwartet also
muss die Produktion anspringen und die
das produktionsmaximum erreichen wir
dann zeitverzögert ähm das das soll
jetzt keine Entschuldigung sein für die
für die langsamen bürokratischen
Prozesse in Europa m aber es es ist
jetzt nicht so dass der Ukraine von
heute auf morgen die Munition ausgehen
würde das gleiche gilt
für das gerne geäußerte aber immer noch
falsche Argument der bestorisia bzw RAS
putiza wie sie auf Russisch heißt also
diese schlampmperiode dazu nur zwei
Informationen gehen Sie mal auf den
weather Channel und schauen Sie wie das
Wetter in orchiv derzeit ist oder in
Cherson sonnig 20° ähm der Süden hat ein
trockenes Steppenklima ähm dort ist die
das putiza weniger von Bedeutung äh wenn
sie in den Osten schauen in den Donbass
dort natürlich schon äh da müssen sie
aber auch denken das ist dann schlimmer
wenn sie im Graben sitzen als als wenn
sie äh wenn Sie einfach in der Ferne
stehen und die Artillerie abschießen ne
also sobald man diese Argumente so ein
bisschen antestet und und durchdenkt
fallen sie auseinander ich kann Ihnen
immer nur empfehlen ähm
lesen Sie wenn Sie wenn Sie das in der
Presse lesen dann gehen sie davon aus
dass dass der Journalist vielleicht
nicht vollständig informiert ist über
die technische und und logistische
Dimension und dann forschen Sie das
einfach mal ein bisschen nach ja schauen
Sie wie das Wetter ist schauen Sie wie
das Gelände aussieht ähm und und kommen
Sie dann zu eigenen Schlussfolgerungen
statt sich davon einfach verängstigen zu
lassen was sie gerade auch schon
angesprochen haben ist natürlich die
Wichtigkeit der Unterstützung aus den
USA und auch die wird gerade debattiert
sie wird mehr debattiert als je zuvor
wäre denn der Westen langfristig also
wir sprechen jetzt wirklich von dem
zeitra über ein Z vi Jahre in der Lage
einen möglichen Ausfall der
usunterstützung
aufzufangen ja sehen Sie ich habe mir
gedacht dass sie mich das fragen würden
deswegen habe ich ihn mal ein paar
Zahlen zusammengestellt damit wir diesen
dieses
Pseudoargument demnächst geht den Amis
das Geld aus für die Ukraine mal
auseinander dröseln können also nächst
mal muss man sich klar machen es gibt
zwei Töpfe in Amerika aus denen kommen
die unterstütz für die Ukraine der eine
Topf unterliegt dem Kongress der andere
nicht das ist nämlich der interessante
das die sogenannte presidential Drawdown
authority das ist sozusagen ein eigenes
finanzierungsrecht das dem
US-Präsidenten zusteht also der
Exekutive und dafür muss er den Kongress
nicht befragen ja der US-Präsident kann
also sagen für jedes Waffensystem das
irgendwo in der Welt herumsteht auf
irgendeiner amerikanischen Basis das
System geht morgen in die Ukraine Punkt
kann er einfach so sagen so jetzt hat er
aber dann ein Problem weil irgendwann
sind diese Lage natürlich auch leer und
dann muss man die nächste Generation
Waffen nachproduzieren also kommt das
Department of Defense und sagt okay wir
sollen jetzt neue Waffen hier in Auftrag
geben gut dann brauchen wir aber Geld
also in diesem Fall muss er tatsächlich
in den Kongress und da das aufgrund des
Kriegsausbruchs natürlich nicht im
normalen Haushaltsplan drinne ist ähm
muss er eine sogenannte supplemental
appropriation beantragen beim Kongress
und das so lief in der Vergangenheit ähm
eben die die die kongressfinanzierung
also das sind per heute ungefähr 113
Milliarden und davon ging über die
Hälfte eben an das DoD also für solche
Programme nicht um die Ukraine selber zu
unterstützen sondern um den Nachfolger
der Waffen zu produzieren
die man jetzt in die Ukraine geliefert
hat ne und ein Drittel geht übrigens an
United States aid also das ist dann vor
allem für die technische und und zivile
Hilfe z.B letzten Winter für die
zerstörten Energie Systeme oder für
allgemein für die Unterstützung der
Zivilbevölkerung das muss man zunächst
einmal wissen damit man sich nicht von
diesem Pseudoargument da ähm ins Boxhorn
jagen lässt und jetzt haben wir eben das
Problem in Amerika ist die
republikanische Minderheit äh Mehrheit
im im Repräsentantenhaus so dünn dass
sie halt die Unterstützung dieser
radikalen Republikaner also sogenannten
freedom caucus benötigen und die sagen
natürlich ja gut aber ähm solange nicht
unsere politischen Ziele auch finanziert
werden kriegt ihr diese
appropriation nicht ja also das ist
eigentlich so so ein interner interner
haushaltsmechanik in den USA aber ich
glaube nicht dass das auf den Krieg
wirklich Auswirkungen hat also das
schlimmste was passieren kann wir reden
ja hier über die Finanzierung der
Exekutive also der der das federal
government nicht über über den Haushalt
insgesamt das schlimmste was passieren
kann ist einfach ein government shutdown
bis zum Ende des budgetjahres das heißt
also die amerikanische Regierung macht
dicht dann machen die Nationalparks
dicht und die müssen in Zwangsurlaub und
am 1 Januar kommt das neue Haushaltsjahr
und es ist Business usual also das
sollte man alles eigentlich wissen und
wenn man das nicht weiß dann habe ich es
jetzt gerade gesagt und ich denke D das
wird dann dieses Argument so ein
bisschen bisschen abmildern ja ich ich
kann das ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr hören
ich lese das jeden Tag in der Presse und
denke nee ist ist nicht so ja ist
natürlich eine Frage die medial viel
debattiert wurde und auch hier unter den
Usern wir haben noch eine Frage aus der
Community haben sie ungefähre zahlen wie
viel Prozent der russischen verfügbaren
artilleriesysteme bereits zerstört
wurden
ähm das ist schwer zu sagen weil wir
nicht genau wissen wie viel russische
artilleriesysteme es überhaupt gibt
die sind schwerer zu zählen als bei den
Panzern was wir aber tatsächlich wissen
ist dass sowohl der 90 Tage Durchschnitt
als auch der 7 Tage Durchschnitt der
russischen artillerieverluste sich auf
dem historischen Höchststand befindet
also wenn Sie eine Zahl haben wollen
allein in dieser Woche sind es 250
artilleriesysteme also sowohl schwere
Artillerie wie z.B gerzind oder Mr s als
auch leichtere artilleriesysteme wie z.B
die 20 oder die30 die zerstört worden
sind und das ist absolut ein
historisches Maximum und das zeigt Ihnen
eben die Wirksamkeit äh und auch die
Präzision äh des ukrainischen
gegenartillerieeuers mhm wir haben noch
eine Frage zu einem anderen Teilbereich
äh und zwar zur Problematik kerschbrücke
wann kann Ihrer Meinung nach die
achillesene Krim Russland für immer
außer Betrieb genommen werden fragt ja
ein User im Chat mhm
ähm das hängt dann an zwei Faktoren zum
einen an der Fähigkeit der Russen diese
Brücke überhaupt noch zu verteidigen und
andererseits äh am Kalkül der Ukraine
lässt man den Russen einen Rückzugsweg
offen oder nicht also wenn wir mal
angucken ähm auf der Krim stehen
insgesamt fünf oder standen besser
gesagt insgesamt 5
S400 Systeme also die modernsten Systeme
die russland hat für die luftverteil
davon hat die Ukraine per heute zwei
vernichtet also drei sind noch da und
zwei von denen
m sollten eigentlich die Brücke von
Kersch schützen wir haben jetzt nun eben
gesehen in der letzten Woche dass es
westlichen Technologien also Marshal
Körpern durchaus gelingen kann diese
Brücke
zu zu treffen wenn es ihnen gelingen
kann die Schwarzmeerflotte zu treffen
und wir haben ja gesehen Hauptquartier
der Schwarzmeerflotte wird getroffen
trotz modernster lu Verteidigungssysteme
die Flotte selber also Schiffe U-Boote
werden getroffen trotz modernster
Verteidigungssysteme also scheint es
durchaus möglich dass auch diese Brücke
selber zu treffen ist ich denke das ist
technisch durchaus möglich und
spätestens wenn die Ukraine attackems
bekommt also diese lang langreichenden
missils mit 300 km Minimum
dann wird das technisch denke ich
möglich sein die Frage ist ob die
Ukraine das will weil sie müssen sich
vorstellen wenn diese Brücke zu ist dann
können die Russen nicht mehr so einfach
abziehen ähm und dann könnte es sein
dass sie versuchen sich irgendwo zu
halten äh oder dass sie versuchen
über den Korridor von von berans
Mariupol rauszugehen
was für die Ukraine schwieriger wäre
weil sie der Rückzug würde dann länger
dauern und vielleicht würden die Russen
noch mal versuchen so eine letzte Abwehr
zu organisieren ich habe ja früher schon
gesagt ein Szenario das ich für
plausibel halte ist dass die Brücke bis
zum Schluss offen bleibt um den Russen
eben diesen Rückzug zu ermöglichen und
erst danach in die Luft gesprengt wird
quasi als großes Finale des Krieges ähm
es ist natürlich eines von vielen
möglichen Szenarien ähm aber ich denke
es es liegt nicht zwingend im Interesse
der Ukraine diese Brücke jetzt schon
rauszunehmen ähm wichtiger ist es die
Logistik zu unterbinden also so das ähm
was ähm vor einem Jahr passiert ist das
Geschenk zu Putins Geburtstag dass man
also sagt wir nehmen ein Stück der
Fahrbahn und ein Stück der Eisenbahn
raus ähm aber die Brücke an sich bleibt
noch stehen
ja und den Abzug der Schwarzmeerflotte
den haben wir heute gar nicht so groß
thematisiert wenn euch das aber
interessiert dann schaut mal auf ZDF
heute vorbei da gibt's einen tollen sehr
übersichtlichen großen Artikel mit allen
aktuellen Informationen den verlinken
wir euch nachher auch noch in der
Infobox wir bleiben noch mal kurz beim
Thema Krim hier fragt ein User auf
Youtube was bezweckt die Ukraine
eigentlich mit den kleinen Einheiten die
auf der Krim zum Einsatz kommen sind
diese nicht dem Tode
geweiht
m kann man nicht so unbedingt sagen also
ähm die Ukraine führt an verschiedenen
Stellen der Front ä Operationen durch
mit Spezialkräften das passiert übrigens
auch am südlichen Ufer des nipro also
gegenüber von ähm von resson ähm ich
denke das das hat nicht wirklich ähm
Relevanz im Sinne von Operationsführung
das ist mehr so ein bisschen an antesten
ähm wie die russische lokale
Verteidigung auf der Krim aussieht also
russland hat ja z.B diese Drachenzähne
äh die wir äh vorhin schon gesehen haben
in einem der Einspieler auch an
verschiedenen Stränden der Krim
aufgebaut also so in in wie soll ich
sagen einer armseligen Imitation des
Atlantikwalls äh wenn Sie die Fotos
sehen also es kommt nicht ganz so hin
wie Atlantikwall ja also Hinweis an die
Zuschauer googelen sie mal Atlantikwall
wie der aussah im Zweiten Weltkrieg und
wenn Sie das vergleichen mit dem was da
in der Krim im Moment rumsteht ist ist
nicht ein Vergleich ähm trotzdem ist es
natürlich auch nicht so einfach da jetzt
reinzumarschieren ich denke sie sie
versuchen bisschen da die die
Schwachstellen rauszufinden vielleicht
auch in Zusammenarbeit mit a tich also
den Partisanen auf der Krim ähm
rauszufinden ob man da möglicherweise
was einschleusen könnte ähm aber ich ich
glaube jetzt nicht dass hier ein großer
Angriff auf die Krim von See her
erfolgen
wird und wir gucken noch mal weiter in
Richtung
Waffensysteme Waffenproduktion die erste
Frage die wir haben auf youtube ist was
für westliche Waffensysteme sind den
russischen klar
überlegen
klar überlegen ja das hängt ein bisschen
davon ab was Sie mit klar überlegen
meinen
aber also sicher würde ich sagen
westliche Marschflugkörper also bisher
haben die Russen scalp der der Franzosen
und Storm Shadow der Engländer nichts
entgegenzusetzen ähm das war eine
riesenblamage das Heiligste militärische
Gebäude Hauptquartier der
Schwarzmeerflotte wird nicht nur
getroffen sondern es es wird so stark
getroffen dass es quasi von ihnen von
innen alles was in dem Gebäude drin ist
in den Innenhof hineinbläst
und mindestens mindestens 37 bestätigte
Personen dabei tötet das das war schon
das war schon ein schwerer Schock und
ich denke das war auch einer der Gründe
warum man jetzt die die die
Schwarzmeerflotte abzieht von von
Sevastopol überlegen würde ich sagen
sind ebenfalls die schweren westlichen
Kampfpanzer sofern sie in ein direktes
panzergefecht mit älterer sowjetischer
Technologie kommen würden also z.B
Challenger 2 oder Leo 2 A6 wenn die
antreten würden GEG t72 da müssten sie
nicht mal auf ihn zufahren allein schon
aus dem Grund dass sie viel höhere
feuerdistanz haben also die könnten den
aus der Ferne
rausnehmen wir könnten ebenso
vergleichen Bradley oder Striker also
die die gepanzerten Fahrzeuge die
eigentlich dazu dienen Infanterie zu
transportieren mit dem russischen BNP 1
ist übrigens auch ein interessanter
Effekt an der Front man man hatte
eigentlich erwartet ich auch dass die
Russen mehr von ihren moderneren
Varianten also den BMP 3 einsetzen
würden tun sie aber nicht und der bmp1
den wir überwiegend an der Front sehen
der ist Baujahr 1960
ähm gibt ihn eine Idee ne also was was
das für eine technologiegeneration ist
also sprich falls es im Laufe dieses
Krieges zu einer direkten Konfrontation
kommen würde von von westlichen äh und
und sowjetischen mechanisierten Systemen
aus den 60er 70er Jahren äh da da gibt
es noch einige Feuerbälle äh ja das das
denke ich schon ja und das Thema
Waffenproduktion Rüstungsindustrie
interessiert unsere User sehr wir haben
hier mehrere Fragen gerade auch zu
Panzerproduktion in Russland da wird zum
einen gefragt
mich würde interessieren wie Herr Kolb
die aktuelle Panzerproduktion in
Russland einschätzt und ein anderer User
fragt wie verändert sich denn das
Kräfteverhältnis aktuell durch die
Produktion in Russland und im Westen
mhm ja ähm ich ich habe mir so in den
vergangenen zwei Wochen mal die die
verschiedenen Zahlen angeguckt also nach
meiner Ansicht ist die Konsensschätzung
bei etwa 20 bis 30 Stück pro Monat die
Russland an Panzern produzieren kann
jetzt muss man aber Vorsicht bisschen
abwägen produzieren heißt in Russland
nicht unbedingt dass das Ganze wirklich
neu zusammengebaut wird das kann auch
heißen dass ältere Panzer die irgendwo
im Lager stehen und
nicht nicht sofort funktionsfähig sind
dass die instand gesetzt werden
z.B nagil oder von von mir aus im im
oralagon WK ähm wenn Sie jetzt denken
wie wie passt das zusammen
die Produktionsrate also ne sein wir mal
optimistisch und sagen 30 pro Monat dann
käme Russland auf eine maximale
Kapazität von 360 Stück pro Jahr nach
der aktuellen abnutzungsrate verliert
Russland aber im Moment 4,5 Kampfpanzer
pro Tag jetzt rechnen Sie das mal hoch
mal 365 und dann gibt ihn das eine Idee
wo die russische panzersituation
hinläuft also wir haben immer noch die
Situation Russland zehrt immer noch von
seinen historischen sowjetischen
Beständen aber sobald die aufgebraucht
sind und sie sehen ja im Moment dass
dass Russland ja begonnen hat schon
uraltsysteme zu aktivieren also t62 oder
55 ich vermute als Überbrückung bis dann
endlich die instandgesetzteren
T80 an der Front ankommen allein dadurch
dass das passiert sehen Sie schon dass
dass diese Industrie nicht wirklich
leistungsfähig ist Putin hat ja vor ich
glaube vor 10 Tagen gesagt okay deswegen
pumpen wir jetzt viel mehr Geld ähm ins
Militärbudget äh aber ich ich habe in
meinem Buch militärökonomie ja damals
schon gesagt ähm man es reicht nicht
einfach Geld hineinzuwerfen in eine
Armee und dann zu erwarten dass unten
militärische Leistung rauskommt ne also
man muss dann sich auch schon mit der
Industrie befassen und das äh das
richtig aufsetzen also insofern glaube
ich nicht dass dass das ein ein Einfluss
hat was wir auch sehen und das habe ich
vorhin vergessen zu erwähnen ist eine
stärkere Abnutzung modernster Systeme
also der russische T9 der ist in den
letzten 10 Tagen viel stärker
abgeschossen worden als im langfristigen
Durchschnitt des ganzen Krieges ähm und
wenn ihnen nicht mal das hilft also sie
werfen ihr modernstes System den T90 an
die Front und trotzdem wird er
abgeschossen ähm tja was was wollen sie
da noch nachliefern instandgesetzte T80
instandgesetzte t72 also ich ich habe
das ja immer scharzhaft genannt
Eskalation nach unten ne also sie können
sich auf der technologiekurve nach unten
bewegen T55 und dann T34 und dann Pferde
und dann Männer mit Säbeln und dann
Männer mit Knüppeln gerne alles aber sie
dürfen sich nicht einbilden dass das was
zu tun hat mit mit gesunder
Industriepolitik Herr Kolb das waren
viele Fragen in sämtliche Richtungen und
ich habe hier ein Kommentar aus der
Community den ich gerne mit Ihnen teilen
würde passt vielleicht auch zu dem was
sie jetzt gerade zuletzt noch mal
festgestellt haben hier schreibt jemand
auf Youtube kbsprognosen sind zu
optimistisch er unterschätzt die
Fähigkeiten der russischen Armee und
überschätzt die Fähigkeiten der Ukraine
und daran anschließend auch gleich die
Frage an Sie anhand von was für
Merkmalen ist denn erkennbar dass
Russland den Krieg strategisch verloren
hat mhm ja ja den den Kommentar begin
bekomme ich häufiger zu hören
interessanterweise nur aus
deutschsprachigen Ländern also wenn sie
mal die Diskussion in Polen England oder
den USA vergleichen
da da würden sie Menschen finden die
noch weit aus optimistischer
argumentieren aber anyway wir wollen uns
darüber nicht streiten ähm aus mehreren
Gründen einerseits weil die gerade
erwähnte nachproduktionskapazität der
Russen nicht nachhaltig ist diese
abnutzungsrate ist langfristig nicht
durchzuhalten zweitens weil ich die
kampffähigen russischen Verbände vor
allem die Eliteeinheiten langsam für
erschöpft halte drittens weil Russland
sich nicht wirklich eingestellt hat auf
einen langfristigen Krieg sondern seit
Beginn dieses Krieges lediglich
improvisiert und ich würde sagen
viertens es gibt auch ein ein nicht ganz
rein technisches argum Argument äh weil
Russland nicht wirklich ein Kriegsziel
hat außer die Vernichtung der Ukraine
als Staat und Nation und da können sie
sich als russischer Soldat Fragen ja gut
aber was habe ich eigentlich mit der
Ukraine zu tun also es hat auch eine
moralische Komponente aber wenn Sie die
Ukraine sind dann wissen Sie ganz genau
was mit ihnen passiert sollte Russland
diesen Krieg gewinnen nämlich die
Vernichtung ihres Staates und ihrer
Nation bzw äh die Umgliederung derselben
in ein Marionettenregime und wenn Sie
das vor Augen haben glaube ich dann
haben hab sie die maximale Motivation
und
auch die die Fähigkeit in in
unkonventioneller Weise zu
denken ja das ist Herr Kolbs letzte
Antwort auf eure Frage Herr Kolb ich
bedanke mich dass sie jetzt so lange mit
uns die Fragen der Community
durchgegangen sind ich bin mir sicher
wir sprechen uns hier im Ukraine Update
noch mal und ich wünsche Ihnen einen
schönen
Abend gerne Ihnen auch schönen Abend
danke
schön ja ich gucke hier zum Schluss noch
mal in den Chat dieses Thema bewegt euch
nach wie vor
hier schreibt z.B jemand auf Youtube
liefert Taurus damit können die
Versorgungslinien abgeschnitten werden
und die Russen müssen sich ohne eInk
Kampf zurückziehen andere haben wir
gerade gehört sehen das aber auch
kritischer und sind sich da nicht ganz
so sicher ich bin mir sicher wir werden
über dieses Thema hier noch eine ganze
Weile diskutieren ich sag bis hierhin
mal danke für euren Input und eure
Kommentare ich wünsche auch euch einen
schönen Abend und bis
bald
ه